she's free to join us tonight and she is
dr. Jill Stein with us now
dr. Stein thanks very much for coming on
you'd think that the party of diversity
would be for more diverse views but
they're not why is that well I'm not
sure it's actually the party of
diversity we got two parties and they're
both working for corporate masters and
the fossil fuel giants and the big banks
and Wall Street and Warmachine and so on
and so you know that's not my opinion
that you know that the Democrats are the
party of diversity but let me say voters
deserve more choices and you know in the
last election we saw over a hundred
million voters the largest bloc of
voters is not voting because they're not
being represented by the system so we
really do need more choices we need non
corporate choices and people-powered
choices and we can have those choices
without fear of splitting the vote there
is a win-win solution here it's called
ranked choice voting the state of Maine
just passed it it's used by millions of
voters around the country so it really
makes obsolete this whole issue of you
know the struggle between well can we
have choices or do we have to force
people into two pigeonholes
that you know the majority of voters
almost 60% of voters are saying that we
need a new independent political party
because they're tired of being thrown
under the bus by the other to whether we
have Democrats or Republicans it's not
working out so well for everyday working
walking there's probably right there
they're locked into debt and so on
we need more choices and we can have it
so let's not keep that a secret we
should require you know these are
electeds to actually pass a simple
reform the state of Maine just did it
it's available to us right now we can
have it under 20 election I've followed
that pretty closely because I'm
interested in Maine I'm not sure I
understand rank-choice voting or many
people in Maine understand it but I
wonder the broader question seems maybe
they do maybe and maybe they do and
maybe I will if I studied harder but you
could not trust me I've tried but here's
the broader question why do the media
cooperate with this effort to shut down
anybody who offers an actual choice to
what we have why wouldn't they be
open-minded enough to let the candidates
speak of their peace let voters decide
and the system worked the way it's
supposed to why do they have to crush
people accuse them of being Russian
agents if they have a different view
well if they were doing their job you
know their job is to educate voters not
to tell voters or to pigeonhole voters
or to vilify voters for expressing their
discontent with two parties that have
thrown them under the bus
you know in the last election we had two
candidates who were the most disliked
and untrusted in modern history and
seventy-five percent of voters were
screaming for open debates they wanted
to hear from the libertarian and the
green they wanted to hear a debate about
for example our war machine which is
going full speed ahead right now the
last tax day the average taxpayer gave
over thirty five hundred dollars
practically to the war machine and $40
to the EPA to give us clean air in water
you know how's that working out for us
baited why I think everything needs to
be debated I'm totally and that's a
place where we agree vehemently are you
gonna run again in 2020 do you think I
do not have any plans to run at this
point there's plenty else to do and you
know I feel like I've done my duty this
time around and you know it's time for
someone else to to carry that banner but
I'm certainly fighting for the cause of
more voices and more choices in every
political great I agree with that a
hundred percent and you're not a Russian
agent if you think that dr. Jill Stein
thank you very much thank you target